Now we're going to set up our development environment. To
get ready, you're going to need to install some things
if you don't already have them installed. The first thing
you're going to need is Java. And you're going to need the
JDK 1.7, also known as Java 7. You probably already
have it on your computer, but if you don't, you're
going to need to download that now. And then the next
thing you're going to need is Apache Maven. And then you're
also going to want to use Eclipse. You don't have
to use Eclipse when you're using Maven projects, but
we strongly recommend it. And during this course, all
the instructions are going to assume you are using Eclipse.
Also recommend that you get Eclipse EE, because it
comes with built in support for Maven. If you
already have standard Eclipse installed, you can add the
Maven m2e plugin to it. But really I think
you're going to have a much better experience if you
just use Eclipse EE. Some of the things in the
Maven plugin for Eclipse don't quite work right. Now
one thing you don't have to install is the App
Engine SDK. And this is because when you have
Maven projects, you specify all the dependencies in a configuration
file called pom.xml. And it's in this pom.xml where you're
going to specify the version of App Engine SDK that you
want and then Maven will just download the App Engine
SDK for you. So if you need help installing any
of these components, we've written a document for you to
help guide you through installing them. And you can find
a link to that document in the instructor notes for
this lesson. So go ahead and install each of these.
And when you've done it, go ahead and check the
box here, so that we know you're ready to continue.